that noise Oh sir you know what trains
responsible parents trying to protect me
now okay now one very little [ __ ] up
keeping all those emails today maybe she
was afraid I'd end up like Walter Lana
okay
oh yeah expert at the video second
option tomatoes uncle under the house
jiggling now that's Ariel how they get
milk oh I can only imagine what else she
was hiding yes seriously as Lori [ __ ]
want to make the same mistakes she made
trying to bury something that's still
alive
Trish gonna find the corpses only one of
us left
or maybe two
I thought it was time I heard the
stories for myself and found out what
happened to everyone else okay but now
I'm worried the stories themselves might
be the problem
amy was so much in a family curse we
made it real holy [ __ ] he did [ __ ]
die but try that's [ __ ] up I can't
tell you what that way I don't know if I
should even be writing this [ __ ] I
guess it far away from that place of are
you maybe it'd be better if all this
just died with me and maybe but I
thought you should know about your
family
oh [ __ ] am i pregnant then or now and
you're the kid you're a part of so yeah
I want to be honest I feel as lost as
you probably do right now
and I would not right but it's out for
all of us
I think people in these stories believe
them for what that's worth
see there's a lot of cool stuff in this
game but you can't actually like slow
down check it out because otherwise
you're like stuck mid-sentence like to
find out the rest of the sense you got
to keep moving forward kind of [ __ ] up
but hey you know how to make this game I
just paid for it with my good own money
and I can look at the house what what
about what our history of imagination
and stubbornness and madness what I say
any of it seems possible
okay I gotta Nexus a half yeah I think
we've been surrounded by desk for so
long we've just gotten used to it all
right
what kind of family finishes building a
cemetery before starting the house and
where we guy is cemetery it's
embarrassing for me to admit this but
what the pet cemetery may be more
uncomfortable than this woman when I'm a
light therapies and regen yep burp HRP
bar fail our phase our phase I can't jet
happy immersive about the house but it
was easy to design the cemetery okay
Molly
Calvin fat and what it Lois died from
what is the same
hop NICUs I get that I think you say
Finch Walter why does he get a [ __ ]
rock opera
I'm sure Odin's my Lords and Edie's idea
my mom was always trying to move on but
3d the past never went away
and that's y'all dig that [ __ ] [ __ ] she
could see it poking out of the water at
low tide
he said she dreamed about the old house
every night thank you music now where am
I where my god my jumping off here I
guess I might time to kill myself indie
side was always easier for me to
understand but the older I get the more
I can see where my mom was coming from
Sam
God Gregory I guess how is Lois she lost
two of her brother's just like I did I
get why she tried to help and we never
found on the body so my mom insisted we
were putting up a monument not the
tombstone okay Oh Robert listen all
these things know things I wish I could
ask my mom now part of me thinks this is
what she wanted all along
never come back someday and find
everything out for myself
yeah sure just hope she just mailed me
away because the place seems like
badness badness
but looking back on it now if she told
me there was going to be so much
climbing I never would have come when I
was 22 weeks pregnant she's 22 weeks
pregnant holy [ __ ] I want to she writing
it why is she doing this that she swings
awake that's what I don't get Wow
okay hell she's 17 I never met grandpa
Sam but I think he and my mom had a lot
in common
sure
short think it out they were that was
pretty intense
Sam spent his life shooting photos but
mom said he got nervous being in front
of the camera I guess we're all afraid
of something huh what's the clothing
[Music]
I don't like leave yet but say that [ __ ]
now now okay
hey [ __ ]
sigh I should call her she's called
Gallio dawn I promise you'll never
forget this weekend yeah these memories
are going to last perfect not [ __ ] let's
cut them off during the whole weekend
isn't it
we just take the damn picture hey
language never forget this okay got it
I'm going to take pictures okay just be
careful a camera's older than you are I
am less are fashioned out
you're right dad is starting to clear up
yes I definitely should not have drunk
all that coffee hey that's my keeper
there better better I'm just saying I'm
not always gonna be here dawn you'll
need to remember this stuff if you want
to survive have you fine dad
you know who else thought he was going
to be fine some guy who died dawn I'm
being serious I know dad you're always
cleaning doesn't being out here make you
want to chill out I'll just tell you the
truth I haven't been out here in 20
years
last time I was with my brother Calvin
man that was a great trip
oh my god what am i celebrating I spent
on a set of guys gone before you take
the shot when they get a picture of them
laughs back
dad I just prayed that let me give you
I want to capture them but them up when
the phone laughter I'm gonna have to do
anything
great shot dawn oh what the [ __ ] kind of
[ __ ] up I'm proud of you dawn
always remember that okay that's a
little messed up sorry dawn just got to
reset the timer I brought it I brought
it dad it's twitching
I think totally normal doc just focus on
the camera try not to think oh oh [ __ ]
that is pakka I did not see that coming
oh wow voila guy oh sorry that's the one
I wish most that my mom had told me that
is [ __ ] doc oh holy [ __ ] wait who was
the girl with him that barb now that's
kind of [ __ ] up now that one really
got me by surprise good out there no
okay okay after Sam died my mom and Edie
got really close they both lost a lot
and I was toys man these guys got some
good [ __ ] can't control Gregory I think
this don't look like one year all right
[ __ ] Margaret and get the forest
lawsuit okay
do you remember the wedding for you ah
fracking he saw things the rest of us
don't
ah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
ah in the Frog master oh you like that
[ __ ] ah like a bag I'm just a lot frog
I know what I can snatch a kiss yeah
[Music]
that's what I'm seeing how long uh how
do I measure well hello oh the [ __ ]
whale just lost Sam I hope you I don't
want to come right now Oh what his world
was like yeah that way yeah come on let
me get this last off we get the [ __ ] out
of here you reminded me so much of
Calais imagination whatever it was he
saw how they all so happy I get out of
here
[Music]
oh [ __ ] I am so pleased with myself
hello measured eyewear yay yeah we're
getting root model full cools our oh how
very place where I'll just sell for you
Freya I know I'm worried about a baby to
that looking away that way
sorry about that Stephanie I know you
think everything you could that I read I
have to call that I want to hear that
Epis you should've told us
Buffy will be song-ah like that I guess
[Music]
now I am that guy gay not everything
join may shine may betcha
uh hello hello well I know what happened
wasn't your fault
yeah you and I got had a - yeah
sure
yeah we have to ah right right good luck
a love Sam okay okay Carl's that bench
hi Roy
and I'm orbiters I put the fast thing in
there now that's chaos the leaves are
people that they wear like with so
k-type are the family beasts married I
think so Sam was the owner that's kind
of [ __ ] up but all right Mike I
thought sec okay Don and got man they
just frakkin Loudoun a lot they were on
a happy here I monitor writing poetry
and yet and yeah what poem I got a poem
for Gus who always said the wedding was
a bad idea
our father never had a kid I was not
very hard before the day my 12-inch
heads with teenage disregard that he'd
be dead before he see a wedding in our
yard
go down go down now [ __ ] I'm really
[ __ ] up this way to Anna
I got up let's not touch okay so what am
I supposed to be up so it's a [ __ ] out
there wedding
[Music]
alright this hang
[Music]
my father made him come of course but
Gus stood far apart
Lucas chitin bottled up the storm inside
the part I guess
yeah oh me [ __ ] this up that's right
come out of it as always we've never met
we don't need a stepmom where the work
that I know for now husband and what has
been wise make a cry alright it's our
[ __ ] where am I supposed to go alright
if your own if you're hearing me to all
of a sudden it's because I'm eating what
is all this smoke
what is that
[Music]
fiction photos came that ordered him to
come here but Gus declines and as a sign
held up his middle finger
what the [ __ ] it deserves to be shot I
mean I mean not like with a gun I mean
with like a nerf gun you know we picked
up and panic eats appeared and quickly
went all the humans that that day was
doing his eyes attention where's the
case I'll talk about oh it's kind of
definitely going to get struck by
lightning that is certain we go up
Charlie alpha yeah beer me is because uh
[ __ ] eating
the rain came down the buckets ends but
no one seemed afraid that nature might
destroy the tens our dad will approve we
made birth of 10 I'll [ __ ] it up
who
all right and flying up two hours late
thunders found as much toothless and
full of angry powers but all my father
said that makes music louder
that's catalyst if I'm not going to end
well for it flow one source that watch
it says I wish that
oh we got a lot where's that what
I need my chair
oh right I wish that I could truly say
I've thought about you on that day out
there on the beach alone to see you the
wind see in phone I'm a jellyfish but I
didn't until we found my spots up not a
wedding day anyway yeah I'm uh I'm
eating some Brussels sprouts okay okay I
wonder what that chewing it
mom told me once if I was a boy they
were going to beat us
huh it's a lot like [ __ ] final
destination Jesus good shout okay
remember got half rules perfect patient
playing outside no mess up dark vault or
dark respect others and Greg I read
teamwork okay let's put the exits are
sure let's go get up there check the
storage [ __ ] see all that is for sure
it is Greg Osby it baby
okay good I was over here yeah my mom
was up to the loft after her brothers
died oh boy
we're talking at the time it was as far
away she could get last year that
everyday [ __ ] haha she spent a summer
building houses in Kolkata where she met
my dad
Sanjay I look at that I'm thinking whoa
compared to India week after graduation
he got a job teaching English good well
don'tdon't die now he actually died this
morning year later crapola doll
when my dad died I don't think mom knew
where else to go well so she came back
I'm sure et was happy to have her back
milk that any death OS and to see kids
in the house again
the house had to get a little bigger but
Edie was used to that
so whatever gone things are good
almost normal happen well best reading
is a hook you know that is so true I
cannot stress that enough it's out but
it didn't last great that what happened
to our beginning at the end Milton's
10th birthday
when Edie gave to the castle I like to
find out what happens a [ __ ] doll oh
did I miss that [ __ ] goes up and out hi
not that yeah
no I [ __ ] lock him up here oh he's
still alive now because they don't have
also disappeared the only thing he left
behind was a room full of paintings oh
yeah
[Music]
I'm a [ __ ] mess no one's gonna
mention that he says trance now Pat
hello
looks like he owns the Hershey factor or
something is eight let's find out what
happened scratch
Nelson Finch in the magic paintbrush
gosh yes oh yes three minute just four
- door - dear yeah
I was four when up and disappeared where
now we'll do us
it's so cool those house hi
well let me go back down so how do I get
out of here
mom spent months searching for my
brother and she sealed the doors I got
that hit man yeah she's like glue them
with like coffee powder box you just got
such a nice setup [ __ ]
whatever Milton had found in the house
mom didn't want it getting out that's
awesome
beautiful how great what does that
[ __ ] trash
ah that's a I don't know what I'm gonna
dot I'm local just straight-up activates
his [ __ ] his spirit can I'll even
refer anything mom definitely blamed et
but I think Lewis blames himself after
he graduated he just spent more and more
time in his room until mom got him a job
at the cannery Lewis you just start I
realized told me to stay out of Lewis's
room oh ouch of that that's my list
that's a cold place no [ __ ] which way do
I go right left on the left for a second
yeah but I [ __ ] missed on
smaller reality lewis's room smells very
very Italian
that part of him lived on look up here
mrs. Finch as Louis's psychiatrist I can
understand your desire for an
explanation as I see it the trouble
began in January shortly after we
convinced our campus's treating with the
substance of these newly Sobell I
believe Lewis first notice the monotony
of his daily life
[Music]
he catch working pennies that's your
department
get out air best Professor Dobson's I
saw the same behavior his mind began to
that's a lot get out of here
yeah slip
100
I asked him to describe it he said he
started seeing imagining a labyrinth
art he feel his way about then something
me that
and to
[ __ ] is that and things that have not
mean
he knew it was all in his head
paralyzes he took it very seriously
I have hoped to find himself
this is so weird
but he found something more what I can
[ __ ] brilliant
how worried about again
day dreaming of cannery hot but he said
Lewis have become a model employee
methodically tireless focus
where's the next fashion the whole new
Louis so I listen go on
it's cousin guys I'm talking about I
even encourage Greta cops brushed around
my finger him Dewberry shamisen class
gosh you told me hello a new friend
hello Allah breath on the edge of a city
he named Luis topia he built the city up
slowly brick by brick
then he made musician Kenny what see
what you're doing it to where life
expelling a person not shed we got the
real look like and songs for them to
play especially God talked about
starting band who's always humming
something sign expression - every day
his imagination grew strong
you no longer spoke at the candy that is
chopping was as reliable as ever
okay from one day it's trucking what at
all the cheering crowds even the stones
under his feet were all in his
imagination so he could do whatever he
wished chef's our third a special
trailer coming on he held an election
for me and he won they begged him to
stay but his mind was already wandering
it became a game
shut up its greatest [ __ ] all that
he'd conquer city then immediately push
on you Lewis
thank you sir tomorrow I go
he started drifting away from our
reality my hand
[ __ ] [ __ ] Rock
Minneapolis Gomorrah
until one day he forgot to go home from
the cannery what's up [ __ ] even as his
mother pleaded with him
part of Lewis kept sailing on
at my wife mother I'm busy
[Music]
in Louisburg he heard rumors over and
that's core handsome Queen this is a
lotion [ __ ] mystic I am you picked up
in pockets Waimea this is [ __ ]
disgusting
the Queen was on her own quest for
worried about rainbows radiant women yay
happiness yay
[Music]
he heard the sound of her rectangular
cell by heart but Silverhawks
[Music]
[Music]
myself is not I guess that his chase led
him to a golden palace east of the sound
of us at the moon okay
even then his logic remain clown should
can we [ __ ] see it now
[Music]
he wondered up all in his imagination
Tony beche ma'am come on calm down but
he was so proud of having created it in
his own eyes he'd become something
greater than a king he said [ __ ] me I'm
a writer
[Music]
a lot or the next bash someone who'd
never known success in the real world I
think it was overwhelming I gotta get it
fighter yeah I'm lucky
but the real Lewis was not the one
chopping him but the one climbing the
step for the golden palace
[Music]
my imagination is as real as my body
told me hard to argue with him
[Music]
just another day at work huh say it puts
my mouth hmm all right help me some
bottle stops oh okay
brain bout glory suds
arrow palace began to forget the world
we know I think it pained him to
remember Lewis the cannery worker
when
we began to despise the man with a royal
contempt
hello bench
so I I do
is like I still thought I could save him
even after he said he was being crowned
king over all the lands of wonder the
palace would be perfect with his
companion
oh thank you thank you fellows they
pushed us away on a little faster
[Music]
including the wise kalakand insisted on
by
advice payments I'll lower the camera
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
after I pay you one
it's Queen weight Holdings each time I
check out putting up a big it was only
one thing left to do
[Music]
not right [ __ ] Celtic homecoming
that's my best
[Music]
West I think you know mrs. Finch your
son was a kind man who will be missed by
all of us who knew him [ __ ] up I did I
seriously miss dogs my brother was
really cool I wish you could have met
him Bob the mother got a cool computer
he was so proud of being Indian I think
for him it was a way to be something
other than just a Finch I'm gonna
pretend I did not mess Don only back
from Lisa's funeral my mom told me to
start packing dogs water again I would
read until the day before we left to
tell Edie I'm not sure if she wanted to
make it easier or harder I wish we'd
stayed
[ __ ] all the missing Milton but I
understand why we left
that's a other Haida my mom ended up
leaving everything behind Sanjay
oh yeah hot [ __ ] okay what happened
that night has been coming for a long
time maybe I should have come sooner
wait did we hit the store yet
Oh eating Odin oh my god we need a tea
and toss
but it had to end one layer all that's
left now is to tell you about that last
night he did man they [ __ ] push that
old lady all the way up to the top every
time how he not uses me
I missed it tonight I am the writer that
whole last days IDI just watched his
pack and didn't say a word until supper
when she raised her glass and said to a
final night together and all of finally
nights apart grandma do you know what I
said about alcohol some of your
medications are very specific enough to
present for you in the hallway
why don't you hold the grown-ups have to
all you know I'm sorry you're right
we're all leaving tomorrow let's just
enjoy our la I'm not leave Edith you're
excused
ah [ __ ] that
the power had been shut off that morning
but edie always had quick hiring when my
mom said the library I don't think she
knew about the other entrance or that he
had a key to it
thing you're afraid of isn't going to
end when you leave the house
Edith has a right to know these stories
my children are dead because of your
story I think it's best if Edith and I
leave tonight we'll have the nursing
home send a van for you in the morning
okay
Wow DHC there's so many stories I wish I
could tell you but it's only time for
what this is about what happened on the
night you were born
now they step on asperity the tide went
way way out
it was the first and last time I ever
saw the old house ground there been an
earthquake out in the middle of the
ocean
they called it lowest tide in a thousand
years
sherry [ __ ] another milk off no I've
seen that house every day of my life
I never thought go back to it when the
foie gras if I lost my way back right
hello's turn around but I couldn't out
there life I got turned around
yeah
I will not turn around
for a while I wonder I guess I'm just
gonna skip that sure I started seeing
however
James I'd forgotten has ever existed
agua
but when I saw them I felt like old
friends that night a lot of things came
back to him
or maybe I came back to them I made it
what is this who is that that's know
[Music]
things I can't explain but does I need
you to try and eat it what are you doing
in here it's mine
Davis mom you're gonna rip it let go the
specials got a reference screen but mom
dragged him did the car go I never saw a
guy my IDI again right the next morning
the band came to pick her up she was
already gone
I check out after that we moved around a
lot
we both tried to make back to that
and what happened a few years 1pi i'm
seventh day now betters my mom doesn't
like to talk about it
but she started getting sick a lot the
rest happened pretty quickly god
she got better for a while and then she
didn't and out alone / in choice to live
[Music]
yeah but I keep that trig alibi
until I found out about you I'm still
not sure what to tell you about all this
[Music]
however at least forever maybe we have
time to understand things but as it is I
think the best we can do is try to open
our eyes
[Music]
appreciate how strange and brief all of
this is holy [ __ ] is that her know was
supposed to be review but now I hope
you'll never see it what that I just
want to meet you
okay I got and tell you all these
stories myself I guess if you're reading
this now things didn't work out that way
so my job pageant well but I know does
that this is where your story begins I'm
sorry I won't be there to see it it's a
lot to ask but I don't want you to be
sad when I'm gone I want you to be
amazed that any of us ever had a chance
to be here at all
good luck
ah what's up [ __ ] a little boy huh
no well that not that
[Music]
no I look really good game wow help
y'all good
I'm sorry about the giant sparrow
especially like a house does not say
that picture in the game and Joshua
hepatic Kelsey hash I knew it well uh
yeah I'm back to playing Brussels
sprouts a brush brush
well I hope you all enjoyed the story
yeah baby so they go wow wow that's not
a pretty good hey Jase you Jill get me
Roger hell out of work so damn geez no
tell I'm sure about these so you should
sink answer that up found out whose is
better on that bits of Java
ya know unlockables program
now thanks John huh pretty funny come
cheap much know how did you
Mandy's artistic I'll go round of
applause did a great job I know where
was this Dan tava had an easy job comes
her and I [ __ ] did barely shut people
do they honest okay producer for those
finishes I got the best job done all i
mister welcome I next guy getting shot
[Music]
the real Eden
no that's Steve great okay like was it a
good job
who's like the writers the writers did a
great job qualities has sent late yeah
like I just says the game sucks make it
better and Design Consultant okay okay
additional VFX okay okay and let's say
it that's not reckoning I can't mr.
Rieger
that animation hello L animation okay
okay there's sulfur going okay Jake
way-hey J's writing Tompa sue like I
wasn't enough writing I neither like
more Megan Ellison okay and is a sky oh
let's say I think area I should know
that niacin until long nail I kind of
catch up
oh hello who's this blonde Oh Jordan
okay nice Hannah nothing and uh
Deborah's happen okay well to say you
happy it's James Meza I thought you know
you're right to be happy
second hit there [ __ ] play testers okay
planning punny specialize o'clock okay
max present a special bag special talent
scout line check out traits for my face
matches the Edit fetch time
damn Diane okay well thanks applying
everyone there yeah